qu' il ya peut-être un dénouement dans
la sphère vincent lambert alors qu'il
est maintenu dans un état végétatif
depuis maintenant plus de dix ans les
médecins ont commencé à procéder
aujourd'hui à l'arrêt des soins de ce
jeune homme
une décision qui a provoqué la colère de
ses parents regardez on s'en parle juste
après depuis quelques heures vincent
lambert ne reçoit plus de traitement ces
dates et c'est à dire endormi de façon
profonde et continue par l'équipe
médicale après six ans de procédure la
justice en a décidé ainsi insupportable
pour la mère de vincent lambert
l'ensemble de la famille a bien été
informé par lettre du médecin ce matin
les pousses de vincent lambert a choisi
de garder le silence
pour son avocat son combat est très
claire elle voit effectivement ses
volontés mise en oeuvre et donc elle ne
peut qu'être satisfaite
les parents de vincent lambert tente
aujourd'hui de nouvelles procédures
leurs avocats ont à nouveau saisi en
urgence le conseil d'état et la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme pour
demander le maintien des soins à leur
fils alors pour être complètement
complet sur ce sujet je vous rappelle un
peu le déroulé des faits c'est le 29
septembre 2008 que vincent lambert est
hospitalisé à reims après un accident de
la route en avril 2013 le protocole de
fin de vie est engagée en accord avec
son épouse
en 2014 le dossier passe une première
fois devant le conseil d'état en mars
2016 le juge des tutelles de reims
confie donc à rachel lambert son épouse
la tutelle de son mari décision
confirmée en appel en 2017 2018 les
expertises confirment que l'état de
vincent lambert et irréversible en avril
2019 la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme rejette le recours des parents
de vincent lambert
concernant le maintien des soins et des
traitements et enfin le 15 mai 2019 le
tribunal administratif de paris rejette
également le recours en urgence des
parents qui demandent la suspension de
la procédure d'arrêt des soins et le
président de la république s'est
prononcé également en disant que
justement il n'avait pas à se prononcer
que ça n'était pas de son ressort
aujourd'hui puisque les parents avaient
fait un dernier appel au président de la
république
qu'est ce que vous en pensez les uns et
les autres ça remue des convictions
personnelles et intimes
on va commencer par vous d'amiens c'est
une affaire assez compliqué car c'est
l'histoire d'une famille qui se déchire
finalement alors en gros d'un côté nous
avons les parents demain
sans lambert proche des milieux
catholiques intégristes qui s'opposent à
l'arrêt des soins de l'autre côté nous
avons rachel donc et la femme l'épousé
de vincent lambert qu'elle aimerait que
la russie ferait exactement sachant
qu'il ya aussi d'autres frères et soeurs
qui sont du côté des parents aussi qui
s'opposent à la reine et son exactement
est le problème si vous voulez c'est que
moi j'ai du mal à fustiger les parents
de vincent lambert dans la mesure où il
n'est pas comment dire naturel
d'accepter la mort de son fils enfin il
s'agit quand même d'une vie humaine est
là derrière on va quand même dire à ses
parents
votre fils on va le débrancher il va
mourir il va de soit que vous nous dites
et c'est pas évident pour les parents
voilà donc après il ya eu également le
demi frère de vincent lambert qui est
allé lui rendre visite et qui a selon
ses dires enfin vincent lambert a pleuré
lorsqu'il a appris qu'il allait mourir
qu'on allait le débrancher donc après
c'est vrai que les lésions cérébrales
sont irréversibles on dit qu'il est plus
conscient et d'un autre côté on a les
parents qui disent mais s'il est
conscient et nous regarde de façon très
intense
oui c'est compliqué alors effectivement
c'est vrai que lorsque les médecins sont
interrogé là-dessus puisque différents
un groupe médicaux se sont penchés ils
ont tous eu la même la même conclusion
du dossier à savoir de d'arrêter ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui l'acharnement
thérapeutique parce qu'ils expliquent
experts effectivement que ce qui est
normal c'est que les parents considèrent
que les signes que vincent lambert
pourrait donner à savoir des doigts qui
bouge ou un regard qui qui vacille etc
ne sont que des réactions j'allais dire
clinique mais qu'il n'ya plus réellement
de vie cérébrale qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous emilie moi je suis pas du
tout d'accord avec toi je pensais avec
tout le respect que j'ai pour eux que
les parents de vincent lambert sont un
petit peu égoïste dans ce cas là parce
qu'effectivement je comprends quand tes
parents tu n'as pas envie de tout enfant
meurt mais en l'occurrence vincent
lambert aujourd'hui n'a plus de vie il
faut penser à sa fin il faut penser à sa
petite fille aussi et je me dis que
vincent lambert s'il l'a dit à sa femme
qui ne voulait pas d'acharnement
c'est qu'il ya une bonne raison après je
voulais juste préciser parce que moi
quand j'ai entendu on va arrêter de le
nourrir et de lui donner à boire je
suivais on va quand même pas laisser
quelqu'un mourir de faim ce qui va pas
ressentir la faim il a pas ressentir la
soie pour ça qu'on parle de sédation
exactement dans un sommeil extrêmement
profond donc ça se tassera percée doit
pas dans la douleur ce sera voilà ce
sera comme s'endormir et ne jamais se
réveiller alors vous posez vous posiez
cette question enfin vous évoquiez le
fait que vincent lambert aurait dit à
son épouse qu'il ne voulait pas fac
lorsqu'ils étaient vivants qu'il ne
voulait pas de dents
un inventaire à petit qui ne l'a pas
couché sur papier est ce que justement
les uns et les autres ça vous a fait
réagir et peut-être entamé des
réflexions des dialogues dans votre
famille pour dire officiellement voilà
ce que je voudrais que moi en face si ça
m'arrivait tient caroline est ce que
vous avez dit pas en prenant le cas de
vincent lambert qui via une sorte de
porte drapeau malgré l es ce que vous
avez dit à votre entourage voilà moi je
veux spécifiquement ceci ou cela oui
forcément ça réveille vraiment des
espèces de alors je sais pas comment ça
s'appelle sais pas si des angoisses ou
des souhaits je dirais que lui il a émis
le souhait ce à différents témoins donc
c'est vrai que son épouse est là avec
elle cette responsabilité aussi
d'honorer sa dernière volonté dont deux
façons dans les deux cas la situation
est extrêmement compliqué je pense que
ce soit sur des parents personnes ça de
gaieté de bien sûr mais il ya toujours
le l'infini mais sans les ports qu'un
miracle se produire donc c'est sûr que
c'est une décision que vraiment qu'on
souhaite à personne
maintenant c'est vrai que ça réveille
des choses où on a envie d'en faire une
discussion voilà en famille vous même
vous avez vous dit je vais les coucher
sur papier mais en ce qui me concerne je
suis moi j'veux pas pour jeu pas du tout
pour l'acharnement thérapeutique
d'accord alors je veux bien qu'on essaye
[Rires]
meurent et aline et mais c'est vrai que
je trouve que l'acharnement parce qu'on
appelle l' acharnement ces rappels
acharnement alors encore un protocole de
fin de vie le
l'hospitalisation c'était en 2008 au
moment de l'accident de la route et le
protocole de fin de vie a été engagée en
2013 donc il s'est passé un laps de
temps entre 2008 et 2013 on a comme vous
dites essayé et puis en 2013 on dit là
il faut donc elle a eu c'est vrai qu'il
ya eu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'années où on a espéré où il a pu
peut-être potentiellement se passer
quelque chose et rien ne s'est passé
je trouve que c'est sain aussi un moment
donné de dire au revoir à quelqu'un et
de continuer son chemin
mais oui effectivement petibon ne se
sent jamais assez concernés par ce type
de situation et c'est vrai que là je
m'en rends compte petit à petit c'est
une erreur de mon côté à chaque fois et
la danse était dans cette affaire ces
horaires on rappelle qu'il ya 1700 kg en
france un de personnes hommes et femmes
en état végétatif
là j'ai l'impression que la spiritualité
prend parfois le dessus c'est ce qui me
fait 900 à fuir peut pas là c'est aussi
une affaire spirituelle parce que c'est
aussi un langage des choses métaphysique
ça on parle de la mort voilà donc
effectivement et c'est à ce moment-là
que j'ai envie de faire je comprends ce
que le seul à la raison et un moment
donné c'est ce que ça veut dire que pour
autant comme vous parlez de raison et
qu'il ne peut pas y avoir de raison
entre guillemets lorsqu'on est proche de
la personne parce que les parents c'est
compliqué la raison pour eux y compris
et pour sa femme s'est compliquée la
raison est ce que la décision finale
s'est elle reviendrait au collège de
médecins et vous pensez qu'à ce moment
là il faudrait plus que les parents ou
là où la femme et leur mot à dire
ouais oui les médecins dans ces cas là
surtout qu'ils aient eu trois collèges
différentes marques alerte sur cette
situation donc là on a envie de se fier
les médecins au dessus de tout on a posé
la question à nos téléspectateurs
l'arrêt des soins de 20 ans béret ce que
vous comprenez ou bien vous dites je ne
comprends pas et vous comprenez à 88%
vous êtes à peu près comme nous sur ce
sur ce plateau même si on on peut aussi
comprendre le désarroi des parents c'est
difficile de dire au revoir à quelqu'un
qu'on aime mais visiblement les médecins
sont avait absolument sur 2,3 collège de
médecins vous disiez et puis enfin
décision rejetée par enfin décision
demande des parents pardon qui a été
rejetée en le 15 mai 2019